[Musik]
auf und davon präsentiert von Edelweiß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
OTM Gemperli ist in die Schweiz
zurückgekehrt er brauchte eine
Auszeit ich bin eigentlich sehr
zielstrebige ein starker Mensch und
verkraften und verlied und plötzlich ist
einfach wie die Situation wie der
Stecker zeht und Zeit Stopp halt es ist
genug da bin ich im Restaurant gestanden
was mache ich jetzt
da ganz
komisch allein auf Mallorca geblieben
ist sein Freund Gabor
ballock ich verm
wir war immer zusammen diese a Jahre
lang wir war überall zusammen wann otma
zurückkommen wird ist
ungewiss dabei hatte alles so gut
angefangen ein eigenes Restaurant dafür
hat ottm alles
investiert die Umbauarbeiten sind streng
der Zeitplan eng W muss machen D muss
vorwärts machen ja das ist jetzt
passiert bald schon liegen die
nervenblank und jetzt hat er sich weh
getan
offen ja einal komplett aufmachen einmal
gab ist neu im Gastgewerbe alle
unterstützen
ihn tabl Hal meine Hand so zit die
spaget
OT dagegen ist ein Profi die Eröffnung
ist ein
Erfolg haben schon viel jetzt wieder
optimiert und eig gemütlich
stimm
auf Island jenseits von allem Trubel
haben zwei Schweizer ihr Paradies
gefunden Steff und Isabel Felix haben
hier eine ferienlodge
gekauft
schön sie vergrößern ihren Traum um drei
weitere
Ferienhäuschen putzen bauen die
Zimmerleute bewirten es ist eine
anstrengende Zeit Insel sind krampfe
krampfe
krampfen in den Sonnenstaat Florida ist
die Familie Chana
gezogen immer so
reauben die Eltern treiben ihr Geschäft
voran Häuser sanieren und
vermieten no problem oder Achtung
schz Lil Rose hat ihren ersten
Schultag aber sie wird falsch eingestuft
oh sie ist in der zweit Klass nicht in
der erste
Klass für das Mädchen bricht die Welt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zusammen am nächsten Morgen in Florida
Lil Rose hat sich wieder beruhigt komm
do schnell her da komm wieder kalt der
lüftig
die Freude auf die Fahrt mit dem
Schulbus hat das Drama am Vorabend
vergessen
lassen
Schulbus jetzt
sch
[Musik]
S
me 8 sorry Norm
time 75
okay woW ist die erste im Schulbus wo
ist sie da ist da ist sie
da
bye geschafft Lil Rose sitzt im
[Applaus]
Schulbus doch in welcher Klasse wird sie
heute landen den noch hat Melanie auf
die Mail die Sie am Vorabend an die
Schulleitung geschickt hatte keine
Antwort
bekommen hi Mel
[Musik]
thank you how are you
onead
sorry
ah
really
and sad happy
with really ok
perfect yeah I know I know than
you
day you über und S gerade in und
verstanden und L in die er Klass
cool mit Gespräch
[Musik]
suchen ich h jetzt n mir Wunder
was
auf Island ist etwas Ruhe eingekehrt der
Winter ist
da die Natur zeigt sich in stiller
Schönheit nur die Auswanderer sind
ununterbrochen
[Musik]
dran hüchen theo ist immer da wo seine
Leute
sind ja
ja
heute sind Pakete mit den Möbeln für die
tin Häuser aus rjawig
angekommen 29
Stück die sind
stark im Herbst hatte eine Truppe
Schweizer zimmerle die
H
erell
was die Zimmerleute reisten in die
Schweiz zurück und für Isabel und ste
begann der
innenausbaute richtig Ausgang
Ausgang sie verlegten Holzböden bauten
die Heizung ein die Einbauschränke
während Wochen schon sind sie am
schuften wir sind e im Moment sehfeden
mit dem mit dem ganze wie entstanden
ist bis jetzt haben wir auch noch nicht
irgendwelche Sachen entdeckt wo man
müsste sagen ja würde wir komplett
andere ja das mag vielleicht man
vielleicht das schm anders platziert hat
vielleicht da oder
da oder vielleicht im Nachhinein hat
vielleicht D Hüs alle gich groß gemacht
aber wir sind total zufrieden und happy
so wie im Moment
ist heute montieren Sie eine
Küche jetzt jetzt ja
als leidenschaftlicher Handwerker war
für steef klar den
Innenausbau den wollen sie selbst machen
Isabelle war jahrelang als Kauffrau in
der Immobilienbranche tätig für sie ist
diese Arbeit komplett neu
Mittel sehr vielzt am
anfangfang bin
ich ir
FA
aberler WN und das weiß ich schon
was ja so klar bring das bring das
und ne sch mit
mir das Liebespaar ist auch ein
Arbeitsteam
geworden
ja mE schon mal los wenn wenn ich finde
es ist jetzt nicht gut
so lau gerade aber im Großen und ganz
schon J re g gefunden und RE Kön dass
man weiß wie der andere halt mal tut und
das ist gut so brauch und wir m wir
sind
dasgessen wir sindam
und Person aber das nicht viel zum
Glück sch nicht so
schwar sicher ist ihr gemeinsamer
Arbeitsplatz hat eine spektakuläre
Aussicht in gut D Monaten sollen auch
Gäste hier den Ausblick
genießen
im touristendörfchen kalarayada ist die
Saison bestens angelaufen das
Ostergeschäft war top das Team rund um
Gabor hat einen neuen Kellner und noch
immer mit dabei ist die bisherige
Besitzerin Corina Hauer trotz OTM
Abwesenheit läuft es
rund ja okay super danke also ich habe
nur Rose gesehen okay hier haben wir
eine das muss immer von allem etwas
hinten kalt stehen wenn hinten jetzt
kein ist stell eins kalt jetzt
aberemacht okay zwei Wochen gegangen ist
nicht so schlimm aber mehr mehr würde
ich das schon nicht so
akzeptieren als G realisiert hatte wie
erschöpft und gerade zuu fertig sein
Freund war hat er ihn ermuntert in die
Schweiz zu fahren bei seiner Familie
soll er Kraft für die bevorstehende
Sommersaison
tanken
[Musik]
danke die ganze bruppe
H
frei es hat auch vorher funktioniert und
das Team ist so ziemlich noch das
gleiche also in dem Sinne es wird auch
weiterhin funktionieren ob oder mit ob
mal mit oder
ohne ja es war natürlich alles ein
bisschen anders gedacht und vereinbart
aber gut die Umstände sind jetzt halt
diese und es läuft nie alles so wie
geplant also in dem Sinne man macht was
man machen muss und es geht
weiter der Betrieb soll weitergehen so
wie es otma aufgegleist
[Musik]
hat danke danke dir
danke gute Erholung
danke nach dem Mittagsservice hat gab
Zimmerstunde am anderen Ende vonada ist
sein
zause imbendigen Alltag mit den Kollegen
und Gästen hat gabau kaum Zeit OTM zu
vermissen momentan hier machen wir alles
rein doch zu Hause in der einsamen
Wohnung da fehlt er ihm
sehr das schlimmste ist alleine schlafen
ich hasse
[Musik]
das
die charers sind beruhigt töcherchen Lil
Rose zweiter schulstatt ist geglückt an
einer burcht in panacea ganz in der Nähe
des Meeres haben sie ein sogenanntes
Kondo erworben dieses müssen Sie nicht
von Grund auf sanieren sondern können es
bald zur Vermietung ausschreiben sie
wollen endlich Geld verdienen noch
einmal kontrollieren was dringend
erneuert werden
[Gelächter]
mussangbereich so
blöd
[Musik]
aber ne her und
neirp
ja sollen Deko und die behbige
Einrichtung sie soll leichten Möbeln und
bunten Kissen Platz machen bisschen
ausgefallen aber trotzdem gemütlich soll
es werden der typische by eben
wo sind Delfin bereits perfekt ist die
Aussicht da ich nicht so viel Arbeit kan
ich wahsin selber allete die wohn W der
Mario auf der andere S von der Bruck am
Schaffen ist im Alligator point das ist
gerade wo GEW und nochit aber wirklich s
sicher ja so mitte ende Februar soll wir
jetzt da den fertig se dass man das den
Kön wirklich
[Musik]
Verm trotz Meeresnähe standardgemäß
gehört zum Kondo ein
[Musik]
Swimmingpool
die Abgeschiedenheit Islands kennt
keinen Stau auf der halbstündigen Fahrt
in die Stadt kommt Isabelle gerade mal
ein Auto
entgegen sie ist unterwegs in den
[Musik]
Sprachkurs natürlich macht Spaß also das
ist das Thema es ist einfach
der ja Lehr wieder bin doch das nicht
gewönnt ich bin doch irgendwie 25 Jahr
mit Schul das ist für mich schon wieder
eine andere herusforder W da mit Stelle
aber ist
gut ist lustig
egelstader ist die größte Stadt im Osten
Islands durch sie führt auch die
beliebte Route 1 die
Ringstraße sie geht einmal rund um die
Insel seit Jahren zieht Island immer
mehr Touristen an und viele Europäer
lassen sich hier nieder die Wirtschaft
floriert hier gibt es Arbeit
entsprechend gut besucht sind die
Sprachkurse hi hi welkommen die lererin
cynthja OSK Crawford ist Atin USA nú þau
Eru ung og ástfangin og hvað þýðir
það
love
Apartment apartment
mhm litla íbúð í Blokk veistu hvað Blokk
er Block
Block
Block hægri og vinstri
Hor Hal verschiedene
buchstabetzt ganz and sprach sch ist
schon
challeng so schön
und
[Gelächter]
hum
[Musik]
so irgendwann einmal wird auch Steff die
Sprache lernen müssen doch noch fehlt
ihm die
me wenn
Sie die beiden wissen immer wo der
andere sich
aufhält Minuten da
dann ist die Pasta
aldente eine gefüllte Vorratskammer ist
auf Island ein
muss das Inselklima ist rau besonders im
Winter schlägt das Wetter blitzartig um
und dann sind die Straßen nicht mehr
passierbar in Kürze ist man eingeschneit
ja ich ma mir schon Sorge wenn es we
nicht gut ist oder stß nicht gut sind
sie Fahrt nicht so GN Schnee be Schnee
und
is und dann wenn sie Schul muss das ist
für sie Ries
rusfg und dann mache ich mir schon
natürlich wssen wenn sie Abfahrt und
wenn sie da kann ich wie das sie war
oder so aber ich hat das Auto da und
könnte eigentlich
jederzeit g fahr wenn war und darum fr
immer dass sie
Fahrt dass ich weiß wo ich muss wenn bis
war
hiü g
ja und manchmal meldet sich halt doch
der körperin muskelkatter zwar aber eine
Verspannung nur
verchach wieder
weg betonier W
gut the du ist
[Musik]
gut
der Frühling ist die schönste Zeit auf
Mallorca viel Sonnenschein und kaum
Touristen Jahr für Jahr haben otma und
Gabor die Insel bereist hier hier
auszuwandern das war schon immer ottmas
Traum doch nun es Gabor allein
hier
hallo das habe ich auch hier
inor
Palma es wird bleiben
für ja ja die Freude anatto ist etwas
und auch gemeinsam
haben gab stammt aus einer großen
Familie allein zu sein und sich gar
einsam zu fühlen das ist neu für ihn ja
er ist in der Schweiz mit der Familie
und mit kann mit Freunde tre alle ich
mit niemand nuron
h fr immer komm zurück und dann er sagt
einfach bald und ich habe gesagt ja bald
kann auch ein DAU aber ich hoffe nicht
das Tattoo sechs Vögelchen ist perfekt
thank you
so
BRM
ja
okay
so
[Musik]
ja das ist sehr schön das gefallt mir
sehr dass das Leben einmal auf eine
Ferieninsel führen würde hat der
gebürtige Ungarn nicht
gerechnet wen ganzlich zu sein das hier
zu kommen das war Plan und die träum von
M
also ich wollte ja in der Schweiz
bleiben und ich habe dort angefangen
meine Leben so aufbauen und
und wie soll ich sagen ich wollte dort
leben und habe sagt das ist ein träum
blablabla und okay dann ich komme mit zu
dir ja weil ja wird gehören
zusammen es ist nicht nur die Einsamkeit
die Gabor nun zu schaffen macht er ist
auch verunsichert wann wird otma
zurückkommen plötzlich hängt vieles in
der
Schwebe ich habe mich so gefreut etwas
selber zu machen wenn nicht alle
Menschen so eine Chance für selber etwas
machen seine eigen Chef zu sein und das
irgendwie ich fühle dass das hat mir
weggenommen aber einfach meine wünsch
ist dass egal in der Schweiz oder hier
aber bekommen meine Leben wieder zurück
wie in der Schweiz war ich habe
gearbeitet ich habe plane gehabt einfach
war alles so schön gerade und jetzt ist
so ich möchte auch einmal irendo zu
Hause fühlen also ich war in der Schweiz
8 Jahre lang ich könnte dort meine Leben
vorstellen bis ich sterbe und jetzt
wieder hier und dann wieder zurück
vielleicht
und ja dass ich möchte wieder zu Hause
sein
[Musik]
ja
manche Dinge brauchen einfach etwas
länger oh
nein g als unter Wasser aber jetzt
ist jetzt W
wir
die Vermietung von Charas mobile home in
Alligator point hat sich wegen eines
Wasserschadens verzögert für einmal
arbeitet Mario allein er war jahrelang
technischer Leiter eines
Elektrizitätswerkes und hat im
wesentlichen immer in einem Team
gearbeitet
tear Superteam
oder
tolle lü
und sch mit
schaffen Team mit der
Frau
der
ja total anders Mem denke ich schon
schon zurück und und dass es mega
schön aber ich denke da W
sowiesoestellt und bin ich auf Moment
bin jetzt
noch ah langang und
so die rintaler sind mit einem
investorenvisum in die USA eingereist
bald schon müssen sie Angestellte
beschäftigen das ist eine Auflage
ansonsten würde visisum nicht erneuert
werden am coastotel Highway wenige
Kilometer von Mobile Home entfernt gibt
es einen vorzüglichen food Truck den
hten SEF and
more
ist
K aber
du gibt es ein Fisch
sandwi liebt den cornog ein Würstchen im
[Musik]
maismel ein meistens nimmt sie es von zu
Hause
mit denn das ist auch eine Kostenfrage
als junge Unternehmer müssen sie ihre
Ausgaben im Auge behalten seit ihrer
Ankunft in den USA haben sie nur
Auslagen braucht halt einiges ja bis
dann das ganze Lauf das ist halt immer
wenn die selbig mach der schwi so
und oder eh
inwiz und daswus
oder mir Glück D wirklich mit gegangen
sind und ich denke ohne das wird sehr
schwierig in der
USA ja
ja aber mir nicht beklag und hung
dur
Theo weiß wo es am schönsten
ist besonders wenn nebenan im Büro
Isabel
arbeitet die Buchhaltung und das ganze
gästemanagement der H for Lodge ist ihr
Aufgabengebiet die let
zeigt ja das das D die
GT sind halt wirklich nicht in gend wo
so großen
touristenstromt ist
und jetzt mit der letzte Saison haben
wir gemerkt dass Nachfrage da wirklich
vorhanden ist und das git wieder Luft
zum sagen mal die nächste Saison wird
noch
besser jetzt kan
Rut nein
neinu
die
qu vom warmen Bett raus in die Kälte ein
drastischer
Schritt noch haben die neuen
Ferienhäuschen
keinser dafür verantwortlich woher sie
Wasser
bekommen man kann nach Grundwasser
bohren kostenpunkt rund 70 000 Franken
oder man hat Glück und findet auch so
eine
Quelle steef hat ein Wasserloch entdeckt
bereits im
Frühjahr die heimische sag wenn es
Wasser im W 28 gr und da ist alles se
vol Schnee und Loch selber ist aber
nicht Wasser und WN Wasser nichtfüht da
Wasser zum bodenus und nicht ist ke
oberflachche Wasser
mehr die Chancen stehen gut dass es eine
Quelle
ist nur wie potent sie ist das wird sich
erst
zeigen bra nicht so so viel Wasser heßt
wir ja morgen eigentlich der Hauptfluss
Dusch Z WC und so weer und ist H und am
wieder Wasser wenn ab der was den wieder
Dusch Z Koch und und WZ Spen und so und
dann ist die ganze Nacht Z
zumffüllen bei jeder Witterung ob Wärme
oder
Eiseskälte während Monaten schon checkt
Steff die
Lage
und lustige Schwiz hat mir immer so
gefallen auf der Waldgrenze ab den wo
der Wald eigentlich gerade hört und das
ist eigentlich genauso
Island auf der Waldgrenze und das ist
mich das perfekt ist K ist gr ist
steinig und das ist da so sch spannend
[Musik]
ist n hingegen hat sich die Familie Char
niedergelassen dazu gehört ein Boot bald
schon wollen sie auch spritzturen
anbieten m weiß du das
M und das Mami hat eine weitere
Geschäftsidee diese wollen sie heute
testen dieas haben viele Ideen und sie
nehmen sich die Freiheit alles
auszuprobieren K denkt ja mal auf der
Mar und den G das sicher den paar
Wochen sofort zwar viel
also nächst Monat
super nicht
erwarten erwartet dass Amfang 50% leer
standand aber ist übertroffen andere
Sache wiederum denkt man den
schnell bra
Geduld die Arbeit mit dem Vergnügen
[Musik]
verbinden die Bootstour geht nach Doc
Island ja ich hab gesehen und da ist
auch no
ein
dog Island ist ein beliebtes
Ausflugsziel an der vergotten
[Musik]
Coast we was machen anders wir machen
mit
daher daher machen F so oder
stört an den einsamen Stränden von dog
Island wollen Sie romantische
Hochzeitszeremonien
anbieten das wei so
genau ich hoffe sehr dass das
Schätzen
strandhochit wad B und das ist gar nicht
nice g also das ist furchtbar ausesehen
wir sind völlig schockiert weiß
noch Platz bitte
undstell da unromantisch irgendwie denkt
wenn schon müss man doch das genau so
ein Ort machen wie mir da sind W STR
Kes so warte mal wieüber oder das
Melanie will Fotos auf den sozialen
Medien posten um für Ihr Angebot Werbung
zu machen es m bisschen üpiger
sie mehr Hergt ja so aber so im groß und
ganze pas zeig me vorstell im Kop so
aber ja andere muss ich noch
[Musik]
abänd aus zwei Wochen sind nun fast zwei
Monate geworden die otma in der Schweiz
verbringt langsam hat er wieder Boden
unter den
Füßen eine dunkle Zeit liegt hinter
ihm diese begann eigentlich schon Wochen
vor der Auswanderung als OTM hier in
Emmenbrücke seinen Vater beerdigen
musste wenig später schon ist er mit
einer großen Trauer im Herzen nach
mallorc
[Musik]
gebrochen rigoros hatte die Trauer
weggeschoben hatte nur ein einziges Ziel
vor Augen die Eröffnung seines
Restaurants auf
Mallorca sein Lebenstraum in den er
alles investiert
hat als der Druck weg war fiel er in ein
[Musik]
Loch passiert ist das eig noch Woche
nach der öffn also wed so eigentlich wie
so quasi der
Alltag und D nacher bin ich eigentlich
wirklich Anwesen und W ke Funktion mit
und es ist mir alles eig Witz viel wurde
nur schon morgen aufst im Bett jetzt
muss ich duschen jetzt muss ich mich
parat machen bin ich im Restaurant
gestanden was ma ich jetzt da klar es
natürlich viel damit was mir in der
familielebt der Todesfall vem Vater und
dann haben wir ja wi Todesfall vom
Schwager Mutter und das ist einfach
irgendwie alles
mitin und einfach Z viel und ich danke
alles daz bit das einfach of negangen
ist es hat auch gar ke zit zum überhaupt
verarbeiten
[Musik]
nü also es ist ja so der Moment ein W
ich dankt ist das die richtige
Entscheidung s das Restaurant in
morcaes V hin Frage und immer minine
plant W ich gemacht habe ich habe FT wo
mir gemacht haben vom Umbau videoselt
und und ich habe mich einfach probiert
an dem festalte und wirk m sag das ist
schon seit mehr als 20 Jahren me Traum
das Restaurant in Mallorca und das kan
jetzt einfach nicht der Vorfall alles
was bei mir passiert ist einfach D das
ges und ich bin einfach froh dass
Mitarbeiter sehr gut zum Betrieb GLT
haben W den das sehr wertvoll ist dass
es der gut witer geht und sie haben
probiert so im Sinn und Geist wen ich
das eigentlich Aufbau hat die der kurze
Zeit dass sie das eigentlich so wier
geführt h und ich bin natürlich auch
froh dass Corina wierhin gutz glugt hat
und aus organisatorischen
übern
nun fühlt er sich wieder kräftig genug
um nach Mallorca
[Musik]
zurückzukehren spätestens beim
Schneetreiben beginnt für die Island
Auswanderer die
Badesaison dann macht ein Besuch im
tamalbad am meisten
Spaß einmal mehr auf der Straße nach
egelstadier kommt ihnen nur ein einziges
Auto entgegen
gut 30 km von ihrem daheim entfernt gibt
es sogenannte W heiße Quellen mitten im
gefrorenen
See
die Außentemperatur liegt bei knapp
unter
Null das Wasser hingegen ist wohlige 41°
warm seit über einem Jahr schon sind die
Schweizer ununterbrochen am
Arbeiten Freitage sind seit sie einen
Fuß auf die Insel gesetzt haben
gestrichen diesmal haben sie das Bad für
sich
allein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
muss sich
das muss ein
mus und das muss und
das
ja
Stunden soch halb Stunde
meist ja es ist für mich ist es
msam sind am schaff
muss und ja mir ist einfach schnell
schnell schnell schnell
schnell also ich
verglich
t ich B bumler und diese
Kombination und plötzlich sind Leute
da das ist
Island Star Schneefall und paar Minuten
später
Sonn in der nächsten Folge von auf und
davon soll auch R am echten
amerikanischen leben
teilhabenang ohne Englischkenntnisse die
Kleine findet schon bald einen
Freund die Eltern haben eine neue
Geschäftsidee sie bieten Campingferien
direkt auf Ihrem Grundstück
an auf Mallorca hat die Hochsaison
begonnen
otma ist wieder zurück auf der
Insel speziell
wieder noch nicht so realisiert dass man
wieder da sind müssen kurz Gäste
begrüßen Personen Corina ist streng mit
OT Taten und keine Worte so und jetzt
mache ich die Bestellung von MO denn OT
muss nachholen was er in den letzten
Wochen verpasst hat Melodie das ist
diese Kalan bei eisigen Temperaturen
haben Isa und Steff endlich Zeit hoffe
jetzt einfach schauk nicht zu fest für
einen einmaligen
Ausflug
nein vor
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schwanzfl
auf und davon präsentiert von
Edelweiß